hey everybody what is going on we are
back talking about the all-new sony
70-200 2.8 gm oss mark ii on the sony
alpha one big thanks to sony singapore
for allowing us to test drive this lens
having said that my thoughts and my
thoughts only now we're gonna do
something a little bit different on this
review we're gonna go right into
performance because we know a lot of you
are more interested in that than the
specs and everything else we'll talk
about that later on in the video but
let's drive right into this lens see how
good it is can it live up to the hype
let's find out by the way i notice a lot
of you aren't subscribed to the channel
we've got a lot of great videos here on
deep culture subscribe like this video
as well helps out our channel quite a
bit with that let's test drive this 70
to 200 f 2.8 gm oss mark ii
hot man
wow is it hot today
things we do for
reviews zacky
[Music]
so
dude it locks on like a sniper
though jesus christ
i love this lens
holy
there's not one shot that's not in focus
yes the a1 is that good
and b this lens is so good on the a1
i don't have an out-of-focus shot unless
he drives by me
[Music]
you put on a highlight weighted metering
and it is beautiful
sony just makes you want to keep buying
their lenses
you know what it is because they're
always known for heavier lenses now all
of a sudden everything's coming lighter
the 51.2 the 3514
and then this thing is light i mean it's
the lightest you know
fast uh zoom i'm gonna go close up on
him let's try the close focusing on this
stay there
very good compression on this
very good close focusing at 70
millimeters i'm about
beautiful
away from him
that's very impressive
yeah do you hear me
yeah there you go there you go do it do
it do it
okay that's great it's great
there you go
where was that you remember that uh dirt
road we shot the ducati at before was
like in a back alley did they close that
thing up here i think so yeah yeah one
little area yeah yeah yeah yeah that was
really nice
i think it's down one of these ways i
think though too yeah that's the thing
i'm gonna show you it's one of them you
want to try to shoot that too or not you
guys good maybe it's down that way maybe
it's that one down there one of those
yeah let's go down there go down there
but we'll walk down there all right so
normally when i shoot alan
obviously he's very fit so
he's not a modest guy by any stretch of
the imagination
so we're gonna go ahead and do a 1980s
motorcycle shot
topless on the bmw
we do these shots all the time
uh
it is what it is we are bobby move move
away i wanna see my other okay go
exactly
[Music]
geek culture will be back right after
these messages
[Music]
this video is brought to you by logitech
here at geek culture gaming is a way of
life and we always enjoy dishing out
headshots with logitech g pro x super
light mouse the lightweight wireless
mouse combines excellent performance
with classy no frills look designed with
pros and engineered to win it offers
crisp and responsive clicks the smooth
operator even allows you to swap out the
magnetic dongle storage compartment for
greater gliding ease check out all of
its other features over at logitechg.com
[Music]
go right to your apps like this like
this and then kind of just do this now
we won't show your face you're okay
right this is gonna be this this shot
that's the shot you see what i mean get
the nice
okay that was hot
i mean literally hot outside i mean
allen looks good of course but it's hot
outside we're sweating hence my shirt
anyway let's dive down a little bit more
to the specs of this lens and the
overall design this is as sony calls it
the world's lightest fast aperture
telephoto zoom lens at 1045 grams
without the tripod mount here it is
really light and it's very compact
people said sony couldn't do that and
they're proving everybody wrong this
lens is a beast it is so well built so
well it's so refined but it's so easy to
carry around i mean usually with a lens
like this i would have the vertical grip
attached this uh alpha one but i don't
need it with this the weight is plenty
um and also the new features on this
lens really do make it shine you got
mode three now so if you if you're
tracking some you know sporadic subjects
that are moving around that mode 3 will
keep the optical stabilization intact
and will keep your shot steady the
focusing on this lens
is lightning quick you saw as i was
tracking alan on the motorcycle going
down the road i'm not missing shots i'm
not missing anything unless he comes too
close to me speaking of close you can
focus up to 0.4 meters at 70 millimeters
away from your subject that is very
close for a 70 to 200 lens and then at
200 millimeters it's .87 there about so
you get really good close focusing with
this which is different than what we saw
on the previous 70 to 200 f 2.8 from
sony this lens they've improved it in so
many ways 11 rounded aperture blades on
this beautiful bokeh in the background
it just disappears a great portraiture
lens you can really get close up on your
subjects great for tracking we also now
have iris lock on this lens that allows
you to lock the aperture so if you're an
a you press iris lock on it locks it in
a then you can control the aperture
through the camera vice versa if you do
not want to have it on a you press lock
it will just keep it from f2f 2.8 to f22
thereabout so you are really well
controlled on this in that regard also
in terms of video you can de-click the
aperture on this as well so sony is now
thinking about videographers as they
would be because a7s 3 alpha 1 etc etc
etc even the fx3 for that matter this
lens is designed for all of that and the
design of this lens is great for
handheld video the stabilization in the
lens with the body you are covered hey
zacky what'd you think about it for
video dude it was like hot knife through
butter it was so smooth that there's
that zoom ring man
and the bokeh on it
yeah damn by the way
i have to say this we're not paid or
sponsored by sony for this okay i just
gotta let you know yes we are waxing
lyrical about this lens because it is
that good sony knocked it out of the
park with this 70 to 200.
they just made a telephoto lens where
you can bring it all around yes i would
bring it for travel oh totally this is
easy pack this in your bag it's not
heavy i brought it with me on my
backpack
i mean honestly compared to the original
70 to 200 i mean this is what 29 or 30
percent weight savings alone and the
size and it's still robust also speaking
of which we've spent on robust we've got
this new lens hood as well if you have a
circular polarizer you can control it
through this um it's newly designed very
nice rubber tip on the end of it always
like that so if you just don't uh you
know scratch up your lens so we got to
keep it looking good right got to keep
this looking good
rubber tip
pun intended
the days of sony's colors being off are
gone
we saw that with the alpha one we saw
that with the a7s3 and the lenses that
are coming out from sony are even
bettering the colors coming out of the
skin tones i mean allen is a very tan
guy
and it just his skin tone glows on this
i mean i have to do minimal editing if i
just want to kind of you know just
brighten up the background or if i would
just want to you know adjust the
highlights and shadows but the skin tone
is beautiful out of this
and that's part and parcel because of
the lens and also the camera system one
great thing that i like about this lens
more than anything else
this is it
7200 is that fast even if you're if
you're a sports photographer wildlife
photographer this is so nice
even if you're in video you need to you
know
change your zoom really quick
it's that simple yes that's right
rooster it's that quick yes
the rooster even agrees
as you should
right he really agrees you know i'm
telling you this
he saw me shooting alan
i mean so did the other people working
out they all stopped and kind of watched
topless allen going around but it is
what it is right we're doing something
different in geek culture we're showing
topless men it's not all about
aliens and
gaming and
anime and
magic cards from dungeons and dragons
that
i mean i don't know
i don't understand it you may do but i'm
here to talk about cameras and lenses
and i
right even the rooster degrees right
whatever
anyway i like this lens a lot honestly
speaking
this impressed me i thought we're gonna
get the a74 to be honest with you when
sony first messaged me about a nda
product
but i'm glad they came out with this now
because this lens was needed for an
alpha one and obviously for the future
bodies that are coming out from sony
that are going to take advantage of this
quick autofocusing system that's inside
of it uh the various different elements
inside the glass that have just improved
the optics so much in this
it is rivaling some of their best lenses
on the market currently
um
i gotta hand to sony they did a great
job with this those are our thoughts on
the 70 to 200 f 2.8 gmos s mark ii we
are fans of it sony once again thank you
for allowing us to test drive this lens
um
there's really no faults i can find on
it i don't know what the price is as of
right now you probably know it at the
time of launch
but i'm guessing it's gonna be priced
pretty aggressively but we've been
waiting for a new 70 to 200 from sony
for quite some time and i'm glad they
did and by the way if you're wondering
how it performs on the alpha one
it's fast you're going to get that max
speed
out of this lens
and if you need that for sports you need
that for wildlife you need that for
whatever you're taking up to 30 frames
you're going to get really close
with this lens anyway
like always follow us on facebook
subscribe to us once again if you
haven't subscribed to the channel we
would love to have you check out a lot
of our videos we do a lot of different
reviews out there a lot of great content
and you know what come and join the
family with that guys take care stay
safe and i'll chat to you soon bye
[Applause]
you